I was showing my parents I was like
something's wrong I was like something's
wrong I have to like call someone and
tell them they like paid me too much
money I like had never seen my name with
that much money in my life before ever
this is the reunion where former College
athletes meet up 10 years later to talk
lessons learned about sports money and
life
[Music]
one thing I love about both you all
stories is it's very clear that you
almost don't know life without soccer
you've been doing it for so long but
when did you know that it could be your
career luckily for me as I was leaving
College the nwsl started so I was able
to play in the first year of that when I
entered College the MLS didn't even
exist so I went to school not thinking
about
making you know having a career in pro
soccer and then it happened quickly as I
was in college the league came about and
an opportunity came to DC United
you know after my junior year I was with
the national team and stuff when I was
younger too like when I was 19 20 and 21
so I think I did know that I could play
probably around 18 or 19 years old when
it comes to finances and you're thinking
about all your options within the soccer
World what was it like kind of juggling
both of those ideas it was tough at
first because you're just not making
what you think you should
um but I think it was just an investment
in myself when you're 20 20 21 years old
and you're turning pro you know at least
for me it was it was about becoming a
pro and succeeding for my teammates for
myself for my family and the financial
part really wasn't that big a deal and
as my career went on each year that
would creep in the financial component
of it would creep in a little bit more
and and that became part of the emphasis
is that fair yeah yeah definitely yeah
give an example of what you mean by the
financial component beginning to creep
in as you excelled well
my first couple years I made all the
rookie mistakes so to speak of you know
I bought an expensive car I uh went in
with my brother on some real estate I
it's like some friends yeah
yeah I had a bar yeah I ran a bar for a
little bit that's pretty cool all the
cliches I I ran through early and I kind
of made a lot a lot of mistakes but also
within those mistakes and those were
those were great learning opportunities
for me once you hit those like later 20s
early 30s you're starting to think about
like oh my I can't play Forever My
Career is going to end soon so I think
that that's obviously when I got my
financial advisor and I'm trying to plan
for the future when I retire I want to
feel comfortable retiring and like
giving that little bit of time to myself
to find a new job and what I'm actually
interested in besides soccer or if it's
going to be with soccer
let's take a little walk down memory
lane
roll the tape kind of look at some
Christy highlights
what was your strength in this moment as
a player
I think I was at a point in my college
career where people relied on me so I
kind of used that as my strength I was
like I have to be the one to take over
the team kind of what does a good goal
feel like obviously I do not know you
just like crave it like you crave like
that moment breathe in after a goal and
it's just like a huge just like sigh of
just like excitement but like relief and
then you get to like share that moment
with your teammates you crave it it's
like addicting
foreign
we all remember that moment where we got
our first big check and you just think
that you could buy the whole world what
is the first thing you bought when you
got a real check for the first time I
must have been 22 and I just got put on
contract with the national team and I
remember looking like opening my mail
and looking at it and I was like that I
was like there's no way this is right
and it now it wasn't that much money but
I like had never seen my name with that
much money in my life before ever and I
was showing my parents I was like
something's wrong I was like something's
wrong I have to like call someone and
tell them they like paid me too much
money I bought a David Yurman ring I
honestly don't even know where it is now
but it was just one of those things that
I wanted so bad at the time but um that
was my first big purchase and I like
felt so good getting it and then I did
feel a little bit guilty after because
it was about half of what my paycheck
was I went and bought a car yeah
the cliche athlete I bought an E430
sport Mercedes it was beautiful and I
walked in and I I say I want that one
and so we did some paperwork he goes you
can't afford this car
and he goes you have no credit because I
just turned Pro I had no credit yeah
so I ended up paying quite a bit of cash
for it because I didn't I couldn't
finance a lot one thing you said earlier
I thought was great was that you
invested in yourself expand on that
investment and how it so beautifully
paid off for you in my early 20s I was
uh doing really well with soccer I was
with the national team
um I was in the nwsl I was a starter so
I was making enough money where I was
where I was comfortable and then I got
cut from the national team and there was
probably five or six years there where I
wasn't I wouldn't say I was struggling
but you know it was like paycheck to
paycheck I wasn't really performing my
best I hit another Point too where I
made it back with the national team and
I'm still with them now and you know
financially I'm in like the best spot
I've been with I've been in in my entire
career so I feel like over these past
eight years ten years getting back with
the national team all those years like
that was kind of an investment in myself
he always goes through these periods
that whether it's injuries now or your
mental health everybody goes through it
that resiliency is a big part of people
having success and both the sports world
and the financial world my adversity was
a little bit different I had 10
surgeries during my career I probably
should have retired a few times but kept
uh kept hobbling back onto the field and
I'm glad I did because you know if I
would have stopped I wouldn't have been
in a World Cup you know maybe not in
Olympics
[Music]
give me a scouting report on College you
I was a lot I was fairly Relentless UVA
was a a real Factory at the times when I
when I went there they had won four
national championships in a row
unfortunately I went there and ruined it
all and we we never won one but it was a
great place to you know to play the game
and it was a really professional
environment so I learned a lot on the
field and I guess a lot off the field
one thing specifically in women's soccer
that has been at the Forefront as it
should be is equal pay and making sure
that you all are compensated for your
work for what you've earned and all of
those things how would you describe to a
person why that fight was and is so
important we have been working just as
hard as the men we have been putting
butts in seats just as many as the men
and I think that we've proven ourselves
to be you know one of the top teams in
America so I think it's just so
important and I want all the young girls
who are playing soccer to know that they
don't have to stop after college like
they can keep playing they can make it a
career like this can be what they do
this can be what they aspire to do I
just think it's it's so important it's
such a good step in the right direction
just for Sports in general not just
women's sports what word would you want
to describe your life in the next 10
years
balanced I have three kids and being a
father and also trying to earn and you
know being a motivated person to
you know succeed whatever that means in
uh in my uh in business or sport or
whatever I choose to do next I think
fulfilled because I feel like as
athletes you're always wanting more if I
was telling my 25 year old self that I
was 32 and still playing I'd be like oh
my God no you're crazy I just feel like
you always want more as an athlete and
at some point I want to feel fulfilled I
want to feel fulfilled of what I
accomplish in my career I want to feel
fulfilled in my personal life so I think
that that's definitely something like I
want to feel like I did everything that
I wanted to
foreign